deutschland als ehemaliger cdu politiker
haben sie ja sicherlich klare
vorstellungen von der definition
bürgerliche partei und bürgerlicher
politiker sehr mir als die beiden
spitzenkandidaten aus brandenburger
sachsen jörg urban und dann zuerst galt
es ja auch als bürgerliche politiker
geadelt hier in der pressekonferenz
würden sie denn auch sagen dass wir ein
hacker der demnächst in thüringen zur
wahl steht ein bürgerlicher politiker
ist natürlich auch kein bürgerlicher
politiker was sollte ich von einem
ehemaligen studienrat denn anders
annehmen ist doch völlig klar dass ein
bürgerlicher politiker ist und die
tatsache dass man zum teil auch
unterschiedliche politische positionen
hat hat ja nichts mit der bürgerlichkeit
zu tun würde sich dann gerne selbst als
bürgerliche politiker bezeichnet wissen
müssen sie ihn fragen lieber angela das
kann ich nur nicht für ihn sagen ich
würde ist so sehen
ich kann mir auch nicht vorstellen dass
die thüringischen und hessischen
behörden die ihn als erbe eingestellt
haben
da irgendwelche zweifel gehabt haben
könnte es denn sein dass afg wähler
gerade in den neuen bundesländern
vielleicht von dem begriff bürgerlich
doch etwas ja abgeschreckt werden weil
sie dann den verdacht haben dass die afg
doch eine zweite cdu werden will
nein das glaube ich nicht der
unterschied zwischen ost und west ist
natürlich dass es im westen eine andere
sozialisation gibt dass die vielen jahre
auch längere parteibindungen
hervorgebracht haben die gibt es im
osten nicht und natürlich ist die
bürgerlichkeit im osten eigentlich erst
nach 1989 wieder erstanden
obwohl es denken sie an den turm das
werk über dresden immer diese
bürgerlichen regierungen in der ddr gab
die eine rolle gespielt haben sie sagen
ja die anderen parteien würden die afg
ausgrenzen aber ist es nicht vielleicht
auch umgekehrt dass sich die afg selbst
ausgrenzt wo sehen sie möglichkeiten mit
regierungsbündnis partnern ins gespräch
zu kommen
das müssen sie eigentlich uns fragen das
müssen sie die anderen fragen und da
kommt es natürlich vor allem auf die cdu
an denn dass die wäre ein möglicher
partner
sie lehnt ist aber jedenfalls ihre
funktionäre lehnen es ab also muss sich
in der cdu erst etwas ändern und was
sich da ändern muss das müssen sie in
cdu fahren wenn man jetzt sieht das ja
die auseinandersetzung zwischen der
alternativen mitte und dem rechten
flügel durchaus auch vor der wahl schon
fahrt aufgenommen hat möglicherweise
könnte das dort eskalieren kann das sein
dass alexander gauland dann als der
große friedensstifter doch noch mal
antreten muss damit die partei nicht
auseinander strebt oder auseinander
fällt also ich glaube überhaupt nicht
dass das eskaliert ich sehe da auch gar
keinen machtkampf
ich sehe eine menge gute kandidaten auch
aus den östlichen bundesländern denn das
ist völlig klar nach dem wahlergebnis
werden brandenburg und sachsen und
wahrscheinlich auch thüring sagen wir
mal ansprüche an den bundesvorstand
stellen